Are you okay?
I'm definitely in a loving,
committed, long term
monogamous relationship with a partner for like two years now.
And after some conversations and multiple metrics to look at,
we decided to move in together for multiple reasons.
And we're maintaining healthy boundaries between everybody
because this is a mixed little village going on here.
And that should not bear any weight
on women's decisions to stay in their marriages.
I'm not married. I'm not gonna get married if there's no common law,
nothing going on here.
So everything I'm saying is absolutely factual.
Leave your shitty marriage.
Do not stay because you have kids.
Don't stay because you have kids cause you're like,
well, nobody else is ever gonna want me.
I'm never gonna be able to find somebody to be with me.
No, that's not even true at fucking all.
For every man that talks shit about single moms and shits on them
and blah, blah, blah,
there's another man right behind him ready to pick you up,
take you on a date and help you out in whatever way they can.
They don't give a fuck. It does not even fucking matter to them.
They see your value as a human,
and they don't see children as a repellent.
So I stand by everything I said.
If you're in a marriage and you're unhappy,
you should get out. If you're.
Especially if you're in a traditional marriage where you even.
If you signed up for It even if you're the one that was like, no,
I chose this, this is what I wanted to do.
You can choose something and then later decide like, oh,
I think I don't like this,
you know, you can stop eating a meal like,
oh, actually,
I'm not gonna finish that.
You can leave a movie early.
Same shit, just a little bit.
Just some different logistics is all I'm saying.
Having children with somebody
does not mean you need to stay in a relationship with them.
Just because you got married does not mean you cannot get divorced.
Divorce is not the end of the world.
You can move on, you can live life,
you can be happy. And it does seem scary.
Yes, it seems super scary.
Cause it's the unknown, you know?
Better the devil you know than the devil you don't,
you know? It's easier to stay where you're comfortable,
you know?
But it's just new, that's all.
Our brains are just, um,
conditioned to be scared about new.
See? But you can do it.
That's why people like me post online,
to show you you can do it.
You can totally leave and it's gonna be rocky
and there was gonna. It's a fucking journey.
But you can do it. Cause if I can do it,
you can do it. If all the other women posting online.
That's why all of us are doing it.
Just a little echo chamber of all of us. Like,
hey, girl,
we're out here doing it. We're out here doing it to show you.
So just because you chose a traditional marriage and chose that life
doesn't mean you can't choose something else for yourself and say,
you know what? But I matter, too,
and you can be an amazing mother.
And in fact,
leaving my marriage caused me to become a much better mother.
And the relationships I now maintain
keep my motherhood at the forefront,
since that is the most important thing to me in my life right now, so.